Jake: 你不吃
Jake: You're not eating?
Jake: 呵呵吃吧
Jake: Haha, eat up.
Jake: 你也不吃
Jake: You're not eating either?
Jake: 就咱俩吃
Jake: So it's just us eating.
Lucia: 有可能但我其实肯定也吃不了多少
Lucia: Maybe, but I probably can't eat much.
Lucia: 但如果完全不吃我可能晚上睡觉
Lucia: But if I don't eat at all, I might not sleep well tonight.
Jake:那咱吃夜宵吧
Jake: Then let's have a late-night snack.
Jake: 要不哈哈哈
Jake: How about that? Haha.
Lucia:一会要吃饭
Lucia: We need to eat later.
Lucia: 就是你选择吃什么吧
Lucia: Just choose what you want to eat.
Lucia:哈哈我都行
Lucia: Haha, I'm fine with anything.
Jake:我想喝粥
Jake: I want some porridge.
Jake:咱都吃馄饨呗
Jake: Let's all eat wontons.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Lucia:呵呵呵
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:别吧的假呀
Alice: No way, it's fake.
Lucia:我算完了老板
Lucia: I'm done, boss.
Lucia:哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Alice:请
Alice: Please.
Lucia:要给你发详单吗
Lucia: Do you need me to send you the detailed bill?
Lucia:654.78
Lucia: 654.78.
Katrina: 你怎么花这么少钱
Katrina: How did you spend so little?
Lucia:啊 我的
Lucia: Ah, my...
Lucia:可能是因为我我没有怎么点过外卖
Lucia: Maybe it's because I don't order takeout often.
Lucia:我每次都是大家点的时候
Lucia: I usually just order when others do.
Lucia:我就跟着点一个嗯
Lucia: I just tag along with their orders, yeah.
Lucia:我甚至觉得我这个挺多
Lucia: I even think this amount is quite a lot.
Lucia:因为我加了我的疫苗
Lucia: Because I included my vaccine costs.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:谢谢老板 实际上我还要在打两针呢
Lucia: Thanks, boss. Actually, I still need two more shots.
Jake:好好好行 没问题
Jake: Okay, okay, sure. No problem.
Katrina: 走上去一看就是一堆capo
Katrina: When you go upstairs, it's just a bunch of capos.
Katrina: 可是一看就是插头
Katrina: But it just looks like plugs.
Lucia:我在接下来这一个月里还要打两针
Lucia: I still need two more shots in the next month.
Katrina: 为什么要交换穿
Katrina: Why swap clothes?
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Shure的女友:你问他嘛想要强盗
Shure's GF: Ask him if he wants to be a robber.
Katrina: 可能他想要体验一下女生的这种感觉
Katrina: Maybe he wants to experience how it feels to be a girl.
Katrina: 但你穿的竟然还好
Katrina: But you actually look okay in it.
Katrina: 不是很唯和 啊
Katrina: Not very girly, uh.
Shure的女友:因为这是男款谢谢
Shure's GF: Because it's men's style, thanks.
Katrina: 噢
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 够了哈哈哈
Katrina: Enough, haha.
Katrina: 快走吧
Katrina: Let's go quickly.
Katrina: 修硕哈哈
Katrina: Shure, haha.
Katrina: 被你折磨的
Katrina: You've tortured me.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Shure: 拜拜
Shure: Bye-bye.
Katrina: 别哭别哭
Katrina: Don't cry, don't cry.
Katrina: 哈哈哈别哭
Katrina: Hahaha, don't cry.
Katrina: 哈哈哈还下雨吗
Katrina: Hahaha, is it still raining?
Shure: 不下啦
Shure: Not anymore.
Katrina: ok
Katrina: Ok.
Alice:刚刚下雨了吗
Alice: Was it raining just now?
Lucia:刚下了哇
Lucia: Yeah, it just rained.
Katrina: 哎呦脚都麻了
Katrina: Oh, my leg is numb.
Katrina: 我去我这么多
Katrina: Wow, I have so much!
Alice:所以刚刚在谈啥呀
Alice: So, what were you guys talking about?
Lucia:刚刚在谈报销的事
Lucia: We were talking about reimbursements.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice:没参加也无所谓吧
Alice: It's okay if I didn't join, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Tasha:你可以报
Tasha: You can still report.
Lucia:放心吧
Lucia: Don't worry.
Katrina: 把我笑死了
Katrina: I'm laughing so hard!
Alice:啊怎么啦
Alice: What happened?
Katrina: 拜拜你回来了
Katrina: Bye bye, you're back!
Jake:拜拜 哈哈
Jake: Bye bye, haha.
Tasha:哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina: 生怕他们再回来烧钱
Katrina: I'm afraid they'll come back and spend more money.
Katrina: 我去算我的钱
Katrina: I'm going to count my money.
Alice:收拾东西
Alice: Pack up your things.
Jake:来 收款码
Jake: Here, the payment code.
Lucia:嗯谢谢老板
Lucia: Mm, thanks, boss.
Lucia:等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a sec.
Lucia:收款码在哪
Lucia: Where’s the payment code?
Lucia:哦好像是这个
Lucia: Oh, it should be this one.
Alice:现在是要一个
Alice: Now we need a...
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Alice:一个什么吗
Alice: A what?
Alice:怎么报账
Alice: How to report expenses?
Alice:是给你账单
Alice: Do you need the bill?
Lucia:自自己加一下也行
Lucia: You can add it yourself too.
Lucia:哈哈哈对给一个
Lucia: Haha, yeah, just give one.
Jake:然后后来给一个账单也行
Jake: You can give the bill later too.
Lucia:行行 对
Lucia: Yeah, sure.
Jake:给一个
Jake: Just one.
Lucia:但是我这都是就是
Lucia: But what I have is...
Lucia:微信淘宝然后京东这些
Lucia: WeChat, Taobao, and JD.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Alice:哎呀别烦我
Alice: Oh, don’t bother me.
Jake:多少来着
Jake: How much was it again?
Jake:600
Jake: 600.
Lucia:我看一眼上哪去了 654.78
Lucia: Let me check, it's 654.78.
Jake:可以很精确谢谢
Jake: Very precise, thank you.
Lucia:我在卫生所
Lucia: I'm at the clinic.
Lucia:那是有发票的
Lucia: There's a receipt for that.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:需要的话可以给你
Lucia: I can give it to you if you need it.
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need.
Alice:你可以帮我按一下计算器吗我不想
Alice: Can you help me press the calculator? I don't want to...
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Jake:记账台是吧
Jake: This is the accounting desk, right?
Jake:这就是账台
Jake: This is the accounting desk.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake:记账台
Jake: Accounting desk.
Lucia:我们也要做balance shit吗难道
Lucia: Do we also have to do balance sheets or what?
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:梯子帐
Lucia: Ladder accounts.
Alice:好啦我把账直接发给你吧
Alice: Alright, I'll send the accounts directly to you.
Jake: 好 呃 你这个很专业
Jake: Okay, uh, you're really professional.
Alice:这是备忘录
Alice: This is a memo.
Alice:就是你可以放图片和文字
Alice: You can put pictures and text in it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:嗯学习学习
Lucia: Yeah, learn it.
Alice:这个
Alice: This.
Katrina: 哎呀哎我们直接算了
Katrina: Oh, let's just do the calculation directly.
Katrina: 你需要我们订单纸那个吗
Katrina: Do you need that order paper from us?
Alice:备忘录里写也行
Alice: Writing it in the memo is fine too.
Katrina: 他不需要的话我们就直接算了
Katrina: If he doesn't need it, we'll just calculate directly.
Katrina: 我先点个粥喝
Katrina: I'll order some porridge first.
Katrina: 看我的红包
Katrina: Look at my red envelope.
Lucia:我也可以用
Lucia: I can use it too.
Katrina: 一个一新币的红包
Katrina: A red envelope with one Singapore dollar.
Jake:嗯啊很多哈哈
Jake: Hmm, yeah, a lot, haha.
Alice:咦
Alice: Eh?
Alice:奇怪呢
Alice: That's strange.
Alice:我给你发一个
Alice: I'll send you one.
Alice:为什么是这样的呢
Alice: Why is it like this?
Alice:给你发一个完整版的
Alice: I'll send you a complete version.
Katrina: 哎 想吃这个如意混沌
Katrina: Oh, I want to eat this lucky wonton.
Katrina: 你们吃啥
Katrina: What are you guys eating?
Jake:呃就你那个店里边
Jake: Uh, just in your shop.
Jake:我们再找一找
Jake: Let's look around some more.
Katrina: 我吃如意馄饨
Katrina: I'm eating RuYi wontons.
Katrina: 你们也吃馄饨吗
Katrina: Do you guys eat wontons too?
Katrina: 你们想吃别的可以点
Katrina: If you want to eat something else, you can order it.
Jake:就是吃馄饨
Jake: We'll just eat wontons.
Jake:大家也没什么想
Jake: No one really has any other preferences.
Jake:你们想吃什么也行
Jake: You can eat whatever you want.
Jake:馄饨就是它
Jake: Wontons it is.
Alice:算了直接截图吧
Alice: Never mind, just take a screenshot.
Lucia:这是啥味的
Lucia: What flavor is this?
Katrina: 虾仁的啊
Katrina: Shrimp.
Lucia:超派虾仁的
Lucia: Super shrimp flavor.
Katrina: 哎大馄饨应该改成小馄饨
Katrina: Hey, big wontons should be renamed to small wontons.
Lucia:我也要这个吧
Lucia: I'll have this too.
Lucia:我要香菜
Lucia: I want cilantro.
Lucia:我好了谢谢
Lucia: I'm done, thanks.
Katrina: 你吃吗嗯
Katrina: Are you going to eat? Hmm?
Katrina: 你不想吃
Katrina: You don't want to eat?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina: 你呢
Katrina: What about you?
Jake:一碗大馄饨50一颗
Jake: A bowl of big wontons is 50 each.
Tasha:sorry
Tasha: Sorry.
Lucia:没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 哎没电了
Katrina: Oh no, the battery is dead.
Lucia:我这也没电了
Lucia: My battery's dead too.
Katrina: 还有多的充电宝呢
Katrina: There are more power banks available.
Jake:有上楼
Jake: Upstairs.
Jake:随便拔
Jake: Just grab one.
Alice:我也弄成PDF
Alice: I'll convert it to PDF too.
Jake:好好你来
Jake: Sure, you do it.
Jake:哈哈哈你拔了
Jake: Haha, you unplugged it.
Alice:因为 那个
Alice: Because, well...
Alice:一弄就变马那啥了
Alice: It always turns into a mess when I do it.
Lucia:嗯截止到目前为止
Lucia: Hmm, up until now...
Lucia:我一个人要的香菜啊
Lucia: I'm the only one who wants cilantro.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia:没事它是一份一份的对
Lucia: It's okay, they serve it individually, right?
Jake:你你你给我哎哎
Jake: You, you, give it to me. Hey, hey.
Jake:呃 唧 好
Jake: Uh, okay, fine.
Jake:给钱哈哈
Jake: Pay up, haha.
Tasha:我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Tasha:那还不够还的
Tasha: That's not enough to return.
Jake:打钱够不够
Jake: Is the payment enough?
Jake:看看
Jake: Take a look.
Tasha:没没坏吧
Tasha: It's not broken, right?
Alice:那就行
Alice: Then it's fine.
Alice:白干
Alice: All for nothing.
Jake:白干哈哈哈那何止白干
Jake: All for nothing? Haha, it's more than just for nothing.
Tasha:何止白干
Tasha: More than just for nothing.
Lucia:何止白干
Lucia: More than just for nothing.
Tasha:八千美金
Lucia:有种跟拼
Lucia: Try competing with us.
Lucia:有种在    打工
Lucia: Try working at Pinduoduo.
Lucia:然后签了竞业协议的感觉
Lucia: And then signing a non-compete agreement.
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Lucia:你们知道那个梗吗
Lucia: Do you know that joke?
Alice:你挑一个
Alice: You pick one.
Lucia:    就是
Lucia: Pinduoduo is...
Lucia:哇我这能说吗
Lucia: Can I say this?
Katrina: 楼上也没有多的充电宝
Katrina: There's no extra power bank upstairs.
Lucia:是影响他们的品牌形象啊
Lucia:就是前几天
Lucia: Just a few days ago...
Jake:怕没有充电宝啊
Jake: Afraid there's no power bank?
Katrina: 都是插了这种的
Katrina: They're all plugged in like this.
Katrina: 充电宝插了摄像机的
Katrina: Power bank connected to the camera.
Jake:对对对是的
Jake: Yeah, yeah, that's right.
Katrina: 你可以
Katrina: You can...
Jake:楼上的那个摄像机好像关了是吧
Jake: The camera upstairs seems to be off, right?
Jake: 对楼上的不录了
Jake: Yes, it's not recording upstairs.
Katrina: 哦哦
Katrina: Oh, okay.
Lucia:就是前前
Lucia: Just the other day...
Alice:所以怎么弄成PDF呢
Alice: So, how do you make it into a PDF?
Jake:呃打印
Jake: Uh, print it.
Lucia:那 嗯备忘录吗
Lucia: Then, uh, notes?
Lucia:备忘录好像可以直接导出成品
Lucia: Notes can be directly exported.
Alice:导出备忘录我发出的这张图片
Alice: Export the notes, I sent this picture.
Jake:来来来来来
Jake: Come, come, come.
Alice:哦 它已经好了
Alice: Oh, it's already done.
Jake:来给你
Jake: Here you go.
Jake:您您继续说
Jake: You can continue talking.
Alice:我我我怎么弄
Alice: How do I... how do I do it?
Lucia:啊没事
Lucia: Ah, it's nothing.
Jake:你放这我再给你
Jake: Put it here, I'll give it to you.
Jake:我给你秀一下
Jake: I'll show you.
Jake:哎接着吧别忘录
Jake: Okay, keep going, don't forget to record.
Alice:然后就打印
Alice: Then just print it.
Alice:哦这样啊
Alice: Oh, like this.
Alice:对然后呢
Alice: Yes, and then?
Jake:然后选择打印机
Jake: Then choose the printer.
Jake:哦也不用
Jake: Oh, you don't need to.
Jake:就这边直接点
Jake: Just click here directly.
Katrina: 点完了吗
Katrina: Did you finish clicking?
Jake:就可以发送了
Jake: Then you can send it.
Jake:这边是pdf
Jake: This is a PDF.
Katrina: 我手机呢
Katrina: Where's my phone?
Lucia:啊哦就是就是
Lucia: Ah, oh, it's just, just...
Lucia:前几天网上一个新闻就是
Lucia: A few days ago, there was news online about Pinduoduo.
Lucia:就是大家知道竟业协议这回事
Lucia: It's about non-compete agreements, you know.
Lucia:嗯对靖康可能知道
Lucia: Yeah, maybe Jingkang knows.
Lucia:就是啊
Lucia: It's like...
Lucia:薇薇之前不知道的话就是没事
Lucia: If Vivi didn't know before, it's fine.
Lucia:这个反正是你到到工作的时候
Lucia: Anyway, you'll only use it when you start working.
Lucia:之后才会才会用到
Lucia: So, some big companies...
Lucia:所以然后就是有的大公司
Lucia: For example, to prevent you from joining...
Lucia:比如说就为了防止你入入职
Lucia: Other companies that are in competition with them.
Lucia:跟他有竞争关系的其他公司
Lucia: They make you sign a non-compete agreement when you join.
Lucia:他在入职时候会跟你签竞业协议就要
Lucia: It's to prevent high-level employees from leaking business secrets.
Lucia:就是防止就是这些高层员工泄露商业
Lucia: The design purpose is this.
Lucia:商业机密
Lucia: But now...
Lucia:他本身是这样的一个
Lucia: Some companies are starting to abuse this.
Lucia:就是design purpose是这个
Lucia: Even entry-level employees, like fresh graduates...
Lucia:然后但是就是
Lucia: Have to sign non-compete agreements.
Lucia:有的公司现在就开始滥用这个
Lucia: Because now it's common for people to change jobs...
Lucia:就是即使是基层员工入职
Lucia: So, there were cases before...
Lucia:比如说刚刚刚毕业应届生这种
Lucia: Where even very ordinary employees...
Lucia:也让他们去签竞业协议
Lucia: Had to sign non-compete agreements.
Lucia:然后因为其实现在就是大家换工
Lucia: And because now it's common for people to change jobs...
Lucia:换工作是很常见的嘛
Lucia: There were cases where...
Lucia:然后就有之前就有好好好些
Lucia: Even very ordinary employees...
Lucia:就是其实很普通的员工
Lucia: Had to sign non-compete agreements.
Lucia:然后他们可能从这公司离职之后
Lucia: And then they might leave the company...
Lucia:然后他进入了一个实际上吧
Lucia: And then he entered a business that he's actually responsible for.
Lucia:他负责的业务
Lucia: His area of expertise.
Lucia:可能跟之前公司也不是那么相关的
Lucia: It might not be directly related to his previous company.
Lucia:这么的新公司
Lucia: Such a new company.
Lucia:然后就是而且他们就是基层打工人
Lucia: And they are just basic workers.
Lucia:所以手上也没有什么商业机密
Lucia: So they don’t have any trade secrets.
Lucia:但是他们的员工司
Lucia: But their company
Lucia:就拿这个竞业协议去起诉他们
Lucia: Sued them using this non-compete agreement.
Lucia:然后让他们赔钱
Lucia: And made them pay compensation.
Lucia:就相当于是白干
Lucia: So it’s like they worked for nothing.
Tasha: 白干
Lucia:对相当于不光白干
Lucia: Yes, they worked for nothing.
Lucia:还要给员工公司赔钱
Lucia: And they still had to compensate the company.
Lucia:就这个事情
Lucia: This thing
Lucia:前段时间
Lucia: Recently
Lucia:反正网上说了好几个这样的例子
Lucia: There were several examples like this online.
Lucia:都是我刚才说的那个
Lucia: Just like the one I mentioned.
Lucia:我就不说一遍了
Lucia: I won’t repeat it.
Lucia:这样一会你方便剪
Lucia: So it’s easier for you to edit.
Lucia:哈哈哈好好
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Lucia:我场记一下
Lucia: Let me mark the scene.
Lucia:我还是挺害怕他们来找我的
Lucia: I'm actually quite afraid they'll come after me.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:我没有
Alice: I don’t have...
Jake:没有没有我把
Jake: No, no, we’ll...
Jake:我们把    给逼掉就行
Jake: We'll just bleep out Pinduoduo.
Jake:我们把逼给逼掉就行
Jake: We'll just bleep out the name.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice:杨老板我来算算你八字吧
Alice: Jake, let me read your fortune.
Jake:啊好啊
Jake: Oh, sure.
Jake:怎么算
Jake: How do you do that?
Katrina: 感觉你有点小魔女的感觉
Katrina: You seem like a little witch.
Jake:请坐请坐
Jake: Please, have a seat.
Alice:哦不用不用不用不用不用不用不用哎呀
Alice: Oh, no need, no need, no need, no need, no need, oh come on.
Jake:请坐大师
Jake: Please, master, have a seat.
Jake:大师请坐
Jake: Master, please sit.
Jake:哈哈大师不得坐着的
Jake: Haha, the master doesn't sit.
Jake:站着大师
Jake: Stand, master.
Jake:没见过站着大师
Jake: Never seen a standing master.
Alice:但你得
Alice: But you need to...
Lucia:但是
Lucia: But
Alice:你知道你的出生时间吗
Alice: Do you know your birth time?
Jake:我好像不知道
Jake: I don't think I know.
Alice:那拜
Alice: Then bye.
Jake:好再见
Jake: Okay, bye.
Alice:百搭 直接百搭
Alice: Perfect match, just perfect match.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 可以算我的吗
Katrina: Can you calculate mine?
Katrina: 我知道我是农历还是阳历
Katrina: I know if it's the lunar or solar calendar.
Katrina: 呃你得出精确到时间
Katrina: Uh, you need to be precise to the time.
Katrina: 我下午1点出生的
Katrina: I was born at 1 PM.
Katrina: 下午1点可以
Katrina: 1 PM is okay.
Alice:1点前一点后
Alice: A bit before or after 1 PM.
Katrina: 一点零几分了
Katrina: A few minutes past 1 PM.
Lucia:不过法律意义上说我这应该不算造谣
Lucia: But legally speaking, this shouldn't count as slander.
Lucia:因为
Lucia: Because
Lucia:我只是复述了我在网上看到的信息
Lucia: I'm just repeating information I saw online.
Alice:那你的生日是
Alice: So your birthday is?
Katrina: 嗯阳历还是农历
Katrina: Um, lunar or solar calendar?
Katrina: 阳历2001
Katrina: Solar, 2001.
Lucia:反正我好多同学都是学法的
Lucia: Anyway, many of my classmates study law.
Lucia:都够组一个律师团了
Lucia: Enough to form a legal team.
Alice:91年12月
Alice: December 1991.
Katrina: 21
Katrina: 21st.
Lucia:下午1点
Lucia: 1 PM.
Alice:1点啊 1点无所谓
Alice: 1 PM, huh? 1 PM doesn't matter.
Alice:1点几分都一样
Alice: A few minutes past 1 PM is the same.
Tasha:现在在干嘛
Tasha: What are you doing now?
Katrina: 现在等饭
Katrina: Waiting for food.
Tasha:哦对你们点饭了 哎
Tasha: Oh right, you ordered food. Hey,
Lucia:你刚才没点吗
Lucia: Didn't you order?
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina: 那你可以睡觉
Katrina: Then you can sleep.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina: 今天睡了一下午好爽啊
Katrina: I had a great nap this afternoon.
Jake:是确实
Jake: Yes, indeed.
Katrina: 而且醒来都都下雨了
Katrina: And when I woke up, it was raining.
Jake:下雨天适合睡觉
Jake: Rainy days are perfect for sleeping.
Alice:请求超时
Alice: Request timed out.
Alice:我们是现场报销吗
Alice: Are we reimbursing on the spot?
Jake:可以
Jake: Yes, we can.
Katrina: 哎呦 哎我买一支彩色笔好像没看见
Katrina: Oh no, I bought a colored pen but I can't find it.
Katrina: 一支彩色笔 没送吗
Katrina: A colored pen. Wasn't it included?
Lucia:没送吗
Lucia: Wasn't it included?
Katrina: 哎取了取了
Katrina: Oh, I found it.
Katrina: 我听谁说好像看见了
Katrina: I heard someone say they saw it.
Lucia:好像看了但是
Lucia: I think I saw it, but...
Lucia:后来又放哪去就不知道了
Lucia: Then I don't know where it went.
Jake:这边还有一袋
Jake: There's another bag here.
Jake:不知道是什么
Jake: Not sure what's inside.
Jake:不知道谁垫的
Jake: Not sure who brought it.
Katrina: 我的我的
Katrina: It's mine, it's mine.
Katrina: 我今天早上找我的牙膏没找到
Katrina: I was looking for my toothpaste this morning but couldn't find it.
Lucia:哦我还买了碘伏和生理盐水
Lucia: Oh, I also bought iodine and saline.
Lucia:不过那东西会也只有我用了
Lucia: But I guess I'm the only one who uses those.
Lucia:没事就算我那个啥也行
Lucia: It's fine, even if I don't use it.
Lucia:反正他也就一新币
Lucia: Anyway, it only cost one dollar.
Tasha:一新币
Tasha: One dollar?
Lucia:对一新币
Lucia: Yes, one dollar.
Lucia:算了不管他了
Lucia: Never mind, forget it.
Lucia:不算了
Lucia: It's not a big deal.
Jake:对回新加坡少坐一次公交车
Jake: Yeah, in Singapore that's less than one bus ride.
Jake:少坐半次公交车
Jake: Less than half a bus ride.
Katrina: 然后我还买了花呢
Katrina: And I also bought flowers.
Lucia:我美团上的单子比较少刚就忘
Lucia: I had fewer orders on Meituan, so I forgot.
Lucia:算了不也没关系
Lucia: Never mind, it's okay.
Lucia:哈哈哈不用
Lucia: Haha, no worries.
Lucia:争取用这个哈哈哈
Lucia: Let's just use this, haha.
Lucia:觉得我现在又饱又饿好奇怪啊
Lucia: I feel both full and hungry, it's weird.
Jake:就是几个胃
Jake: It's like having multiple stomachs.
Lucia:其实我有点想吃东西
Lucia: Actually, I kind of want to eat something.
Lucia:但是就是我没有那种特别饿的感觉
Lucia: But I don't feel really hungry.
Alice:上面还有提拉米苏
Alice: There's still some tiramisu left upstairs.
Lucia:刚才吃了一大块
Lucia: I just had a big piece.
Tasha:好腻刚刚吃了一块
Tasha: It's so rich, I just had a piece.
Jake:最多吃一个
Jake: One piece is enough.
Alice:很甜蜜
Alice: It's really sweet.
Jake:那确实一天最多吃一个
Jake: Yeah, you can only have one piece a day.
Lucia:很好吃但是吃多了确实会有一点
Lucia: It's delicious but if you eat too much, it gets a bit...
Lucia:太甜了
Lucia: It's too sweet.
Lucia:糖分摄入超标
Lucia: Sugar intake is over the limit.
Tasha:然后今天晚上就把房子拆了就行是吧
Tasha: So, we just need to tear down the house tonight, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:那我现在去拆
Tasha: Then I'll go tear it down now.
Tasha:然后晚上就不用拆了
Tasha: So, we don't have to do it tonight.
Jake:对 好
Jake: Yes, good.
Jake:现在拆吧
Jake: Start tearing it down now.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Tasha:你也拆
Tasha: You too.
Alice:报账吗老板
Alice: Boss, should I report this?
Jake:可以报
Jake: Yes, you can report it.
Lucia:我也拆
Lucia: I'll tear it down too.
Tasha:嗯嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Jake:我来砸
Jake: I'll smash it.
Tasha:那人家不跑了
Tasha: Then they won't run away.
Tasha:收拾完了 啊
Tasha: All cleaned up, ah.
Tasha:我可以摘眼镜了吗
Tasha: Can I take off my glasses now?
Jake:你玩啥猫
Jake: What cat are you playing with?
Tasha:你这些拿的都不是他爱吃的
Tasha: You're not taking anything he likes to eat.
Jake:那他爱吃啥肉
Jake: What kind of meat does he like?
Tasha:肉有吗
Tasha: Is there any meat?
Tasha:有吗
Tasha: Is there?
Jake:我没有肉 我还能有肉
Jake: I don't have meat. Do I look like I have meat?
Katrina: 哦哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh.
Alice:我的意思是他需要这原料啥的
Alice: What I mean is he needs these ingredients and stuff.
Alice:他可以拿走点
Alice: He can take some.
Alice:因为我没有那个机器
Alice: Because I don't have that machine.
Alice:薇薇你需要给你收一点啥东西吗
Alice: Tasha, do you need me to collect anything for you?
Tasha:不用我房间也收拾好了
Tasha: No, my room is all cleaned up.
Alice:你这些原料什么的你看你就用得上了
Alice: You can use these ingredients and stuff.
Tasha:快了
Tasha: Almost done.
Jake:嘿嘿嘿
Jake: Hehehe.
Alice:真的吗嗯
Alice: Really?
Tasha:对 但是你不理它
Tasha: Yes, but if you ignore it.
Tasha:它一会就回来了
Tasha: It will come back soon.
Tasha:它只会离人半丈远
Tasha: It will only stay half a zhang away from people.
Tasha:帮我把彩旗摘下来
Tasha: Help me take down the flags.
Jake:好嘞好的
Jake: Okay, sure.
Jake:亲自挂的
Jake: I personally hung them up.
Jake:亲自摘
Jake: Pick it yourself.
Tasha:别把我电脑踩了 踩吧
Tasha: Don't step on my computer. Go ahead, step on it.
Tasha:墙没坏吧
Tasha: Is the wall okay?
Jake:这个怎么让他
Jake: How do you make this...
Tasha:哎呦我的天呐
Tasha: Oh my god!
Tasha:你撕的真好
Tasha: You really tore it well.
Jake:哎谢谢
Jake: Oh, thanks.
Tasha:不会把墙撕坏的
Tasha: You won't tear the wall down.
Tasha:这是纸胶带
Tasha: This is paper tape.
Tasha:明天再把被子和玩偶一收就完成了
Tasha: Just gather the quilt and toys tomorrow, and it'll be done.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:哎呦我靠哎呀呀
Jake: Oh wow, oh my gosh.
Tasha:谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Jake:有在门口的纸箱
Jake: There are boxes at the door.
Jake:就是大门口
Jake: Right at the front door.
Tasha:喜欢哪一个
Tasha: Which one do you like?
Tasha:啊我收拾完了
Tasha: Ah, I finished packing.
Jake:收拾完了哦
Jake: Finished packing, huh?
Jake:你有几个箱子
Jake: How many boxes do you have?
Jake:得带着走不
Jake: Are you taking them with you?
Tasha:寄回去
Tasha: I'll send them back.
Jake:寄 怎么寄
Jake: Send them? How?
Tasha:寄回家
Jake:就是
Tasha:顺顺风上门吧
Jake:明天约很多
Jake: Schedule a lot for tomorrow.
Tasha:那我就摘眼镜了
Tasha: Then I'll take off my glasses.
Tasha:我房间也打扫了
Tasha: I cleaned my room too.
Jake:好好好
Jake: Good, good, good.
Tasha:我我去躺着了
Tasha: I'm going to lie down.
Jake:好好好
Jake: Good, good, good.
Tasha:我手机也呢
Tasha: Where's my phone?
Tasha:啊哦在这
Tasha: Oh, here it is.
Jake:装家累还是拆家累
Jake: Is it more tiring to set up a home or to take it apart?